there's four branches of government and
the fourth is called Silicon Valley yeah
and they're stronger than the rest of
the three of them question I get a lot
in college campuses and then we can get
into the tech stuff is that students
that are in the middle there there they
come after this this is the best case
scenario at times but it's not correct
where they say well yeah the left has
gone out of control but the right has
also gone really out of control I say to
myself what do you meet there is no
moral equivalency between the two where
is right wing and Tifa where is well
they'll tell you it's the KKK they
there's 45 of them and every time they
try to materialize anywhere its
unilateral uniform and overwhelming
denouncement of these people right just
out of control denotes yeah I think we
should just hit that though because I
don't even if what happened if what
happened a couple weeks ago with with
ice yeah it would be attacked okay well
we have or with Andy even right with
Andy no go ahead on I mean if either one
of those things had come out of the
right whatever that is whether you see n
n Sunday night special yeah we may be
having a town hall where Marco Rubio
would be getting strung up I mean that's
right yeah and so they Virtue's signal a
lot better than us but what I'm trying
to say is I'm not trying to say we're
like better people and we deserve all
this but boy our worldview is better
than them right now a hundred percent
because if you're a member of Congress
and you're asked a specific question
will you denounce an Tifa which if for
all intents and purposes in my mind is a
domestic terror organization they're a
domestic terror organization they should
be treated as such how do you assault a
journalist like that with masks with
concrete milkshakes send him to a
hospital and not be called a domestic
terror you have or even organization you
have a hierarchy you have a common
meeting place I mean all this stuff that
because yeah they're doing that dirty
work everything the FBI there's like a
checklist that the FBI has and what a
terror group is they qualify all
domestic terror group I mean they have
specific targets right they they all
this sort of thing and yet total silence
amongst the left complete and total
silence and I'm rooting I'm rooting for
people like Delaney and Andrew yang is
Andrew yang denounced it yeah Andrew
yang had the best weakness that then
we'll get to the tech stuff the best
tweet he said and I
it was just kind of this very
interesting observation he's it IQ
that's amazing he's got really smart
guys he's misguided in the EBI thing but
that's okay
and I said um I noticed conservatives
follow a lot more liberals on Twitter
than liberals follow conservatives on
Twitter did you see this yeah I thought
and I said he he's getting there give
him like give him five more months in
the circus he's going to be very he's
gonna have a different view of the left
than he did a year and a half ago and
then we're gonna get to the
disagreements up but I'm with you on
that because he keeps you know I had him
in here and I think he's in my way your
interview with him was fantastic
thank you really good not necessary to
say but it's fake honest he I think I
think you're basically right because
even when I asked him what his
progressive politics were everything he
said was about equality you know I'm for
gay marriage or something like that and
it's like but that's not progressive
anymore because we've progressed to it
we've progressed to equality so in my
view he really is an old-school liberal
and yes on some of the big government
stuff and whatever you think about you
bi he's not there but I think once he's
done with this evil machine he's gonna
in a weird way he could end up being
more right than I think said most
liberals I think that probably is where
I'll end up low weight let's okay fine
all right I want to move to the disagree
odds we've been too nice to each other
here we are you wrote a piece in The
Washington Post about big tech a couple
weeks ago and everyone that's watching
this knows that where I'm at right now
is the libertarian side of me that
thinks that the market can can solve
everything or at least that the market
is the best way yes to solve problems
not that they're always going to be
solved but that's the best way that's
being pushed to its limit the rubber is
meeting the road I think the tech
companies have gotten so out of control
with the bannings with the shadow
bannings with the D monetization z--
with algorithms that nobody seems to
know how to control or are being
manipulated and I could go on and on
with it's ileane other things your
argument basically was yeah I don't want
the government doing anything but here
we are that's that's the but and now the
but of course is where that's where the
problem start kicking in if you hold an
ideal that markets are supposed to solve
these things so I'm not there
it's not a bear it's a really tough
conversation dude I'm so glad we're
having it because I'm a Milton Friedman
guy I'm a free market free people wait
New York Times had him on the cover he
said he's Indian all right yeah zero
you're right that was the most
ridiculous piece yeah that I've seen my
dad 40 years he's had the New York Times
I think even longer than I've been born
he had it for like 45 years still
subscribed nothing like seeing the son's
head this was all right dishonest pieces
of journalism ever seen you have one guy
like one guy yeah and it's just this
pablum thousands of words of nonsense
anyway that that's a different thing at
a different I've invited the author
another field Milton Friedman yeah
Milton Friedman guy I'm a thomas soul
guy I believe markets do solve solutions
for those that are listening or watching
that aren't sure what my view of markets
are it's that free people exchanging
goods in a free society voluntarily
mutually cooperating as they see fit
will benefit society benefit the
individual and that that's essentially a
market so a couple things in order for a
market to operate you also believe in
private property that's a big thing so
you have impartial courts that can
adjudicate differences so you're not an
anarchist I'm not an anarchist Adam
Smith talked about the importance of
impartial courts because you're gonna
have differences of properties and not
just physical property but intellectual
property and all that and also of course
the price system that's really really
important Milton Friedman talks how
prices are the language how we
communicate with each other so if
tomorrow Starbucks made every single cup
of coffee twenty five dollars which is
not inconceivable considering they're I
mean they're gonna lower the prices you
exactly that the upward trajectory that
they're on for coffee there's there's
something to be said that less people
lie that coffee and that's how you
communicate no one actually might open
that some people might open their voice
would be upset but the the silent
regression from buying their coffee will
be reflected in their balance sheet and
that's how we communicate value the
value prices are super important so I
think the first thing we talk about tech
is we all suck we first admit we really
don't have a market in tech there's a
couple reasons behind this and then we
have to talk about some of the problems
that I think everyone admits first of
all there's a lot of cronyism that
exists between the big tech companies
right now whether it be government
contracts whether it be far too extended
patents that are given to Google we need
to think about this I think that patents
in a lot of ways our anti free market
and I
we should shrink the window of how long
some of these patents are so you said it
the best mm-hmm Google has this
algorithm that no one can figure out
right but they also have it patented and
they have a patent for a very long time
and so if it were to be put off the
patent market well it's also made public
mm-hmm and if someone could compete
against it that's an interesting thing
to think about that there could be a
fritter that they're actually hiding
behind some of the government favors
that are given it right so it's a weird
place to be though because you're sort
of asking for government interference of
this back-end freedom so let's let's go
to what we want yeah I think let's I
always tell our team at Turning Point
USA every every time what does success
look like well Charlie's success looks
like 1,400 high school kids in DC in
August great how do we get that we work
backwards to where we are today let's
let's do that why not take me on this
voyage what does success look like fair
free and open platforms or different
ideas can express themselves multiple
tech companies not four but dozens of
tech companies competing for our
interests that are able to you know have
these ideas present hopefully an
improving product over time and
hopefully a search engine that doesn't
have 92% of the market share I don't
think that's a healthy thing I just
don't I think even 40% would be a lot
ninety degrees so that that's where a
success would look like a disaggregation
let's call it that decentralization I
think that's probably a fair so you
would agree at that right now
and also you not having to battle
YouTube non-stop and you're not having
to do all these things you actually
focus on content creation I've asked you
Dave how many hundreds of hours have you
spent of wasted energy on this stuff oh
it's been I mean I have to fight them
publicly constantly it's like it's not
sells you right well it's not fun it's
it's not that it's it's a note well it's
bad business because I'm putting cow
content that I end up losing money on
I'm in a weird way there are times where
I'm doing the producers the more things
that I make the more money I lose yes
which is not fun but also it's just
publicly it's not fun to have to attack
the your own your own platform but okay
so so far I'm with you on the ideas but
now we're we're going to have our
problem is here here's the question of
functional part is the the question is
so let's say we deregulate some of the
patents definitely but is it enough and
I'm at a place right now where Tiger
Carlson says something really
interesting to me and really stuck with
me
said Charlie we need to think about this
who is more powerful the IRS or Google
and I immediately said the IRS because
that's what we conservatives believe
like we believe that government has
uniform power I defended it I thought
pretty well Google doesn't have the
power of audit school can't put you in
prison you know all these IRS could do
all those sorts of things Ryan IRS can
wreck your business and Tucker retorted
with a really interesting thing he said
well but Google can't shut down your
business yeah I guess that's right and I
debater a little bit and Google can
manipulate entire society bleep
something that might not be true and we
went through the whole litany of how
powerful Google was and I thought about
it for months
and I think it's really important thing
that we conservatives do we actually are
always challenging our positions I think
that's what's so healthy about our
movement and it hit me about a month and
a half ago when I was using I and my
laptop open and I my gmail account
watching YouTube you know I'm a Google
Calendar yeah and I said my goodness
they know everything about me the IRS
doesn't know crap beerus knows a couple
bank statement you know my taxes my bank
statements that's a very small picture
of my actual activity and I thought to
myself and I might have this computer
open I said what if one engineer in
Google was flipping through Twitter and
saw one of my tweets praising President
Trump and he said screw this charlie
Kirk guy I'm going and he goes to work
tomorrow and he decides to look at
everything about me mm-hmm
do we know that's not happening I mean I
think we can go onto the assumption that
it is happening that's really scary
that's more power than the NSA has and
by the way we know that Google is so
slanted in the wrong direction
ideologically we know they've shown
regret for not doing enough in 2016 we
know the political imbalance their
political contributions were over a
million dollars to Hillary Clinton and
zero dollars to Donald Trump in 2016 as
far as political contributions they
fired James tamori so here's the
question is is there in place for the
federal government to get engaged or
involved tinker around the edges or
chain or do something to change the way
that this is currently happening and the
piece I wrote in The Washington Post was
first admitting how this could go wrong
so let's just can I start there is that
okay yeah yeah so so that's why that's
why I brought up the piece because I
think you did try to at least
acknowledge
yeah freakin murky road that this thing
and struggling with this because I'm a
free market so great I believe this
guy's see this beautiful society creator
by the free market and I say but what
about this these companies sound
struggling that is a good thing to
struggle cuz and you actually might find
reasonability somewhere and so the first
pieces let's see how this could go wrong
okay
more times than not when you apply
regulation on a very very big company
the regulation get ends up getting
written by those companies the
regulation gets lobbied for the by those
companies there's last-minute middle the
night changes being put by senators and
K Street law firms and lobbying x'
lobbyists that end up actually
benefiting the very company that's
supposed to regulate right it ends up
hurting the competition that's trying to
upstart because they can never side with
the regulations okay so now you're so
far you're giving me stuff that I'm with
you I'm talk about this why we opened up
with this yeah right and so let's but it
took it was a very agreeable example
this dodd-frank dodd-frank for those
yeah I don't know that are watching this
was a banking regulation bill passed out
of out of the 2008 financial crisis
offered by Chris Dodd and Barney Frank
to try to regulate the big banks to try
to never allow the 2008 financial crisis
to happen again but essentially what it
would be is he's like okay I lost my arm
in a horrible motorcycle accident and
I'm taking pepto-bismol for a stomach
it's like complete wrong treatment is it
there nothing to do with this so they
apply the wrong treatment to an
ill-advised poorly analyzed problem and
what ended up happening was the big five
or six banks Goldman Wells Fargo Bank of
America JP Morgan Chase you know these
these massive massive banks that have
trillions and trillions hundreds that
tens a billion tens of trillions of
dollars of assets collectively they
lobby for regulation that they
understand that they can comply with now
they're even to bigger to fail and what
has happened you now have Wells Fargo
you've boa
you've JPMorgan with stock prices that
have never been higher with more power
than ever had and what did dodd-frank do
we have seen a massive decrease and
decline in community banking massive
because for the bank the local bank of
sac
mento let's just take a local bank of
Sacramento that might have 250 million
dollars in deposits and they might do a
couple minute let's say 12 million in
revenue you know they've got some good
loans out healthy balance sheets all
that but all of a sudden a federal
regulator walks in with an encyclopedia
of new regulation they have to comply
with and they say well this is gonna
cost at $800,000 in Lok Lak and they're
well sorry this is the new law well
$800,000 for JPMorgan is called lunch
that's nothing I mean it's nothing then
so what ends up happening is it penalize
it so I'm admitting I'm being voted so
then you're at so this is a huge
concession on your part of the piece
aren't being vulnerable of how I've come
to this because I first want to just
tell the audience that I'm not dealing
in absolutes here at all I'm dealing it
very much of there's there's there's
context and there's texture to this so
anyway so how regulation could be a
weapon use and fit you saw this with
Facebook though you saw this a Facebook
where Facebook actually put forth this
proposal of how to protect people's
privacy
sounds like for 450,000 pages of garbage
it was basically written by you know
Sheryl Sandberg and Mark Zuckerberg how
their company can thrive and rule the
world okay
that's stupid so then the question is
how do we get to that success and I
think what I wrote in the piece is the
number one thing that we can do is
change section 602 I think that's the
number I get it's the 206 or 6 I do I
can be dyslexic at times so I think its
602 in the technology code that was
passed the 1990s that out that allows
these technology platforms to hide
behind the label of being a platform
when they're really acting like a
publisher so the Rubin report right the
any of these companies
you guys are publishers right quite me
if I'm wrong yes I'm responsible
I'll get the contents right so if you
look I put out writer and say something
horribly libelous about somebody and
publish it behind your name you could be
held accountable for that libel suit
okay now a platform right a platform is
supposed to be an open forum where no
one could be held accountable to it
however where they get around it is
where they have these community
standards right
she's the sneaky way of oh we're gonna
kind of curb out who we don't right
exactly one is so trying to break
outside of the binary box since the
piece I've thought of this more and I've
gotten some really good feedback on it
there can be a third box created too
it's like you can have a platform
publisher and then social network cuz
they're not either they're definitely
acting like a publisher they're
pretending to be a platform but why not
create a third box and have an Internet
Bill of Rights that's an interesting
idea I'm not saying that's a hundred
percent what I believe but why not
because when you're consuming so much
information online and so many people
are there live loads are online and
we're gravitating towards online what's
to say that there shouldn't be that kind
of third box and so there's a very
aggressive community of says regulate
these companies for all the regulators
Adam it's very tempting to do that
because you want to seek vengeance
against these companies that are doing
these horrible horrible things but my
whole thing right here is that something
needs to change government alee we're at
that point mm-hmm what that something is
I'm open minded to I proposed in the
Washington Post piece that got a ton of
play got more males in that piece i
think than any other thing i've written
because you got the six the 602 code is
the opening you that's where you that's
where i think we have to change it so
okay so i like the platform verse
publisher debate and I think you're
right they are acting now as publishers
not open platforms so I think there's
something there I think where I would
still be struggling is okay so we even I
can get you with you on the internet but
all right so I would love that if you're
if you're a well publisher let's say if
you're a platform as they're pretending
to be and you have certain things to
abide by but now that but so that sounds
good right road to hell is paved with
good intentions
now we've got something that sounds good
but then to enforce it what are you
going to do what is the government going
to do suddenly you have a good jillion
bureaucrats running around these
companies making sure that they're doing
all of those things and it's like well
do the middle management government
bureaucrats have any insight I could
tell these companies operate internally
I could tell you what you do you you
create a division in the Department of
Justice that's focus on in an Internet
Civil Rights it's no different than free
expression that was challenged in the
70s and 80s and a lot of different in
the gay community was you know there was
a huge there was huge controversy in the
nineteen
in California in particular a lot of
lawsuits that stemmed out of that there
was a creation eventually in the
department justice that focused on said
how is it any different Dave when you
get the kind of penalisation that you
have done on social media or when
Crowder gets D monetized how is that not
a violation of your freedom of
expression and some also would have
private company I don't want to force
that bagger to bake the cake of course I
completely and totally understand that
but then you are publisher you're
discriminating mm-hmm if you want the
point of being a publisher is you don't
take everyone's piece yeah right right
right that that's the whole that's
that's the whole idea of being a
publisher and so the other the other
interesting thing Dave a question to
challenge you is when at what point
what's the breaking point for you
because because what does what if google
showed us all up Shapiro Crowder Knowles
Clavin Daily wire me Prager overnight
would then we say we go after them with
government and here's the other question
i well first let me just adopting them
right so I've been posing this actually
when I cuz this is what I've been
talking about mostly at colleges lately
and I posed that question if they were
to digitally assassinate me today if
they just all of them just agree Twitter
down youtube down Facebook down and
Instagram down would that be a violation
of my civil right and I think it's as
close as you can possibly get to yes
they could they could just take you out
of what the new public sphere is and and
especially the way that technology is
evolving so fast you could almost argue
that your ability to be on those
platforms in some weird way is almost
paramount than your ability to just
exist yeah on a day to day basis which
is a sort of you know very philip k dick
to think about so my question for you
Dave is are we there yet
and if not when will we be and do then
that I'm there okay so let's let's say I
see it so so Tucker and I have done this
several times on his show so let's say I
grant you that then explain this to me
Trump happens to be favorable to some of
the people that you're mentioning here
he's he's on the right side of this
issue I would say
what happens now Trump loses in 2020
you've got president Elizabeth Warren
who wants its code 230 my guys were
telling me by the way not 602 C we fact
check I'm here the rubric forces that
wasn't even dyslexia that was just a
made-up yeah it wasn't made up it was
music I'm sorry I got a lose number
you've just lost all credibility for a
and I really thought you were doing well
this hour no all right now we've got
president Elizabeth Warren who would be
more than happy as a far left
progressive to do everything that she
can to have the government take over
everything and now you've already handed
her this power now I think I know your
answer is gonna be she's gonna do it
anyway whether Trump moves on it or not
the left will come for it anyway but
that still seems crazily dangerous to me
you had a terrible pressure hold it
depends on how we structure this in a
way again I think I think the challenge
is whenever possible we're going back to
the doctrine of Adam Smith so here's the
question Dave private property you've
private property rights don't you we all
do yeah so aren't all your videos you
put on YouTube your property and you've
monetized them and so under the Adam
Smith doctrine of markets you well
technically I don't know if I actually
just honestly don't know off the top of
my head with whatever crazy thing I've
signed with you these are the videos
that I put there so that's an
interesting question yeah you're
definitely the intellectual property
right the icy shores production biast
all that is yours yeah and you've
monetized it and I think from what I
understand you've gone into a
cooperative with YouTube I'm guessing
that they have the rights to it once you
do you sign over the rights but isn't
there anything to say like but this is
my video I've created this whether
that's been adjudicated or not I'm not
sure but I think the solution has to go
through the courts and this is me
believing the courts have been highly
politicized in what many many recent
years the long lasting legacy of Donald
Trump will be hopefully the rebalancing
the federal judiciary away from slanted
radicalism and towards hopefully kind of
very restrained kind of restrained
what's the word textualism
being more texts to us and so that's the
question is so if Elizabeth Warren
starts to go on a rampage you could you
hopefully you can be able to sue and you
can use the courts to uphold these
things and that's under you know under
Obama there were decisions that
he what he was not crazy about so your
basic belief if we were to widdle all
this down would be that the three
branches of government would still be
able to function in a way hopefully we
might not that would that would protect
us from the government let me go a step
further
yeah there's four branches of government
and the fourth is called Silicon Valley
yeah and they're stronger than the rest
of three of them that's that that's
we're on that where we have a super
government that's been created where the
Kingdom of DC is no longer the most
powerful fiefdom in this game of Thrones
that the power is in Silicon Valley and
this is where Tucker is on this issue
this is where dennis prager is on this
issue in the IRS to give you 98 IRS they
don't even accept emails you have to you
have to set a snail letter to them like
a listen snail mail letter to them I
again they might be morally corrupted
but these guys at Google I mean they're
literally building new limbs for people
right I mean they've driverless cars
highly technological people and so
indeed here's my question for you as a
libertarian did you subdue support
looking retrospectively back in history
the trust-busting that Teddy Roosevelt
did in the 1900 right so I get it I mean
this is the slippery slope thing always
right there's a libertarian argument
that would be against the civil rights
act that I think is a no so I disagree
with the two and I'm not for relitigate
in it but I think there is there is a
libertarian argument there but this is
where I would say I would say this is
the difference between basically a
classical liberal and a libertarian I do
find some utility for the state so
nothing that you're saying to me you're
nothing you're saying is completely
outlandish sure and I think if anything
for whatever whatever disagreement there
is here in a weird way we need to keep
that disagreement do you think that's
fair to say because totally because that
way it keeps either side from in account
and not gonna get far and not allowing
your motion runs and I think to keep it
in check
I just so it's a very interesting
conversation because the the growing in
the kind of conservative libertarian
world and reading Hayek and reading
Rothbard I've been told my entire life
and I agree with this up until the last
couple months where I told the true
monopoly is government and it's just not
true anymore we have companies that
could do things the government cannot do
yeah and that's never been the case in
human history it's just never been the
case
it just hasn't where you have a
government that can shut off the entire
lines of communication for millions of
people you have a government that can
say we want everyone to think that Sam's
Deli is closed tomorrow
so when Google's Sam's delts closed even
though it's open yeah that's called you
have an entire super government that's
been created that can manipulate the
entire behavioral pattern of a society
and so if that actually if we could
admit that stronger than the government
then do we use government against it and
some and again I admit it although how
that could go wrong you could actually
end up making those those powerful but I
want to go back to where I see where I
saw what a success looks like and this
this has to be like the moonshot we're
gonna get to the moon and this is the
advice I gave the President Trump
publicly where I think the president
should issue a big challenge saying to
the entrepreneurs of America go start
the next tech company I'm going to use
your platform I'm gonna use as many
platforms as I can touch go do it right
now go raise the capital I believe in
you almost like creating entrepreneurial
activity around this well Kirk as you
know we're taping this at the end of
July right now this is gonna air in
August cuz I'm off the grid for August
you might be interested in perhaps an
announcement that someone might be
making at the beginning of September I
don't want to say too much but that but
if you want to ping that Trump guy and
tell them sure but yes I love all that
stuff and I'm not I'm not saying Andy
Young's are exclusive yeah I'm saying
we've we've identified the problem we
understand the significance of it we
understand how we could solve it
incorrectly because the first thing you
do in medicine is what first do no harm
that's the first thing so we have this
problem and we could end up actually
making it worse
and that would be horrible wouldn't it
imagine if we passed all this regulation
measures we had this crazy bill passed
through Congress we felt great about
then 18 months later all of a sudden we
find out that Google got all these
last-minute provisions and it's not
being enforced and they're ending up not
92% of search results they have 99
percent of search results and everyone
gets taken off the market and that would
be really that would be defeating the
road to hell man all right listen we
have to wrap one ogo internally
obviously obviously we're doing this
again and you know look if we ended up
getting booted from the platform's I
guess we'll just have to keep doing this
in person until it get text this video
to people
they'll take us down Thank You charlie
for more on Charlie follow him at
charlie kirk 11 and don't forget to
click that subscribe button and make
sure the bail is solid to get all the
notifications for our videos thanks for
watching everybody
[Music]